[Applause]
your majesty
mommy
the scale of this evening celebration
and the outpouring of warmth and
affection
over this whole jubilee weekend
is our way
of saying thank
you thank you from your family
the country
the commonwealth
in fact the whole world
on behalf
of us all
i wanted to pay my own tribute
to your lifetime of selfless service
in pictures
in words
and in light
[Applause]
your your family
now spans four generations
you are our head of state
and you are also
our mother
your strength and stay
is much missed this evening
but i am sure he is here in spirit
my papa would have
enjoyed the show
and
joined us wholeheartedly
in celebrating
all you continue to do
for your country
and your people
looking back
we think
of the countless state occasions that
are milestones along this nation's road
and you
will think of red boxes
filled with government papers
at the end of the day
you will remember
those who have led this country
indeed all the countries you serve
and leaders
across the entire world
how things have changed
we think of all you have done to make
the commonwealth
such an important force for good
you continue to make history
and there was still time for fun amongst
the work
we might
have been celebrating that derby winner
this evening
[Applause]
next year perhaps
but i know what really gets my mother up
in the morning
is all of you ladies and gentlemen
all of you watching at home
represented here tonight in this great
audience
your majesty you've been with us in our
difficult times
and you bring us together
to celebrate moments of pride
joy
and happiness
maybe this year
it really is coming home
you
you have met us and talked with us
you laugh and cry with us
and most importantly
you have been there for us for these 70
years
you pledged to serve your whole life
you continue to deliver
that
is why we are here
that
is what we celebrate tonight
these pictures
on your house
are the story of your life
and ours
so your majesty
that is why we all say thank you
now
now ladies and gentlemen i know the
queen is watching
these celebrations with much emotion
having i hope finished her marmalade
sandwich
including immense regret that she cannot
be here in person with us this evening
but
windsor castle
is barely 20 miles away
so if we cheer loudly enough
she might
might just hear us
so
let's all join together
thank you
you